that will give us the same number
available a Bradley
[Music]
the University of california-berkeley
has a public mission and a deep sense of
public responsibility we find that our
students our faculty and our community
are looking for ways to put data science
to work in all sorts of domains cisterna
society three years ago a group of us
took up this question how a university
education could equip its students to
not just be a consumer of the data rich
world they live in
but really a producer of insight this is
particularly important for Berkeley as a
public institution but really is part of
the question facing academic
institutions nationwide when we were
designing this course we were looking at
two questions from the very beginning
how could we make it available and
accessible to the entire undergraduate
population that's a question of scale
but it's also a question of
accessibility what we wanted to make
sure didn't happen with the students
would get bogged down in learning how to
install software or that nitty-gritty of
using applications that are just
difficult to work by hosting it in as
you're a single Jupiter hub instance we
can control the environment
consult anything they just login and
ready to go we're a very diverse group
the students are from about 60 different
ranges and about 85 different
combinations of measures it is important
that everyone gets to decide what data
should be analyzed or what questions
should be asked of the data using the
skills of data science I'm able to look
at these questions and be sure that I'm
doing my best to conduct good science by
using these tools to really understand
the data and what it's telling me I was
exposed to a lot of social inequity in
my life so I wanted to do something to
address that and to minimalize impact on
my community and my family the course
definitely changed my mode of thinking I
like to now look at the big picture
perspective and look at what data is
available on it we could quantify that
data visualize that data now we can move
on to addressing the problem it assigns
for social good brings to bear the
skills and tools and capacities for
thought on all kinds of problems that
matter to our society they conclude
anything from social movements and
political mobilization to protecting the
environment seeing especially through
the eyes of our students the power of
data science to address social
challenges and change
[Music]